Congratulations.
We've reached a branching
point in our lesson.
Now a few different ideas
have been introduced,
so it's important to
orient ourselves here
before moving forward
in various directions.
Now, what motivated this lesson?
Well, we learned
about RSA encryption.
And RSA depended on two things.
One, that prime
factorization is difficult.
So if I multiply two big
primes together, P1 and P2,
and I give you N, I can
trust, or feel secure,
in knowing that you'll take a
long time to find those primes,
and maybe more
than your lifetime.
Also, two, RSA requires that
those large primes I generated
was easy, meaning I could just
quickly generate a large prime.
So let's return to the
first problem, difficulty
of prime factorization.
Well, what is it about
prime factorization, or just
prime numbers themselves,
which make problems hard?
And to find out, we begin
with a core problem.
Given x, is x
prime or composite,
which is a primality test.
Now, we ended up building some
solutions to this problem.
And in doing so, we
realized that this problem
was computationally expensive.
That is, there was no instant
solution to this problem.
As our input number
grew, the amount of time
or the amount of steps
involved for our algorithm
to find the solution also grew.
And how much it grew we
actually understand better now,
because we can predict
this search space
using the prime number theorem.
Though, the real issue can be
thought of as a graph where,
on the vertical axis, we
have the number of steps
our algorithm takes.
So you could just
think of it as time.
And on the x-axis,
is the input size.
And as input size
increased, so did time.
And the problem we had is
that the shape of this curve
is unacceptable.
Because in our case, once
N hit even 20 digits,
we can no longer solve the
problem, in the worst case.
And if we threw an
input hundreds of digits
long at our algorithm, we can
all agree it would not work.
In our case, it would crash.
So it's practically
impossible to check
if large input is prime
using our current strategies.
Now let's return to the
first point, factorization.
Realize, based on our current
understanding in this lesson,
factorization has to be
harder than a primality test.
That is, there are
more steps involved
in finding the prime
factorization of some number,
versus just telling me
if a number is prime,
since, remember, factorization
requires us to find all
the prime factors for
some input, N. Whereas,
a primality test only requires
that we find one divisor.
And a nice reminder of this is
that some users have actually
turned these primality tests
into prime factorization
algorithms, simply
by repeating after it
finds its first divisor.
So the primality
test is just kind
of a sub routine inside the
main factorization algorithm.
So if we return to this graph,
a factorization algorithm
would be something like this.
As input grows, our
factorization algorithm
would be above this
primality test line.
And realize that,
in any situation,
we always have a
computational limit, that
is the number of primitive
steps we can calculate,
which is based on our computing
power in any given situation
and the amount of time we had.
And you could think of
this as a horizontal line,
or a threshold on this graph.
Anything above this
line is out of reach,
not feasible to solve.
And in this lesson,
we were limited
by the Rover's on-board
computer, which
was fairly slow, which is why
we couldn't run primality tests
on numbers with even 20 digits.
However, even if we had,
say, 1,000 computers running
for a year, this would simply
just push this horizontal line
up to some other threshold.
And this would allow us to
run tests on larger numbers.
But as you can see, we
would always hit some limit
where the input is large enough
that we can no longer solve
the problems again.
Now, this leads to many
interesting question paths.
However, I'll identify the
two I'm going to explore next.
First of all, so far, I
have not been very precise
about these growth curves.
Though, it would be helpful
if, imagine, for any algorithm
you give me, no matter
what it's trying to solve,
and no matter what machine
it's even running on,
we could draw some corresponding
growth curve on this graph,
simply by looking at the
description of the algorithm.
If we could do this, we
could identify categories
of certain growth
shapes which tell us
how difficult problem
will be to solve.
And in this way, we could
understand an algorithm
before we even run it.
That's very important
to think about.
And you could hand
me your algorithm
written on a piece of paper.
And I could look at it.
And I'll say, I know
this algorithm is not
solvable with the
input size needed.
And this leads us to a
lesson on time complexity,
an incredibly important
conceptual tool we will need.
And if you've ever heard, oh,
this runs in polynomial time,
or exponential time,
these are terms
which come out of
time complexity.
Next, many of you have
been wondering, well,
how are we generating these
random primes in practice,
that second point
I made about RSA.
Well, let's just walk
through it quickly.
To generate a large, random
prime number hundreds of digits
long, we need to follow
these instructions.
Generate a random number.
Test if it's prime.
If it's prime, we're done.
If not, try again,
until we hit a prime.
Now in this
three-step procedure,
what's most important
is the second step,
test if it's prime.
If we can't do that
step, this won't work.
So how is this working today?
Well, it's based on a subtle
alteration to our problem
definition, and
more importantly,
the use of randomness.
And this leads us to another
lesson on random algorithms.
And now, finally, if there any
other lingering question paths
you have, please
post them below.
And we can plan lessons.
For example, there are
some deeper mathematics
we have yet to explore, in order
to speed up our existing trial
division primality tests.
And what else are
you thinking of?
Please share below.